ce qui me PLA c'est que ça a du sens
mais bon fa le piéger le
sens arrête de regarder mange ça se
mange la cuisine oui mais ça se
regardeord moi j'aurais mis ma purée là
comme ça moi j'aurais collé mon Poas là
j'aurais mis mon HCHO dessus et j'aurais
mis la ligne de d'olive d'olive là de
piment aussi mais le piment alors
peut-être sur l'arrière parce que quand
ils vont le manger regarde ils auront
qui vont se m c'est comme ça que c'est
intéressant tu vois comme ça
là as de l'amertume as le
sucre je sais pas après tu as le
gingembre qui amène la puissance là moi
je trouve que c'est équilibré je sais
pas qu'est-ce tu V rajouter moi un autre
légume non je sais pas on connait la
force et l'expression de de Michel mais
je crois que aussi Sébastien véritable
expression une véritable sensibilité qui
est différente mais on est toujours chez
les bras moitié campagne moitié cuisine
à ma jeunesse c'était ça c'est plus
facile de monter que que de rester en
permanence c'est nos enfants on serit au
Japon dire ah non je bouge rien on
continue comme c'est fait depuis depuis
100 150 ans et on touche rien du tout et
voilà pourquoi j'ai pas envie de de tout
casser pour tout reconstruire derrière
c'est quoi qui marche garouou les
garouou ça chauffe au dernier moment
donc ça c'est pas la peine bon est-ce
que c'est une passation je sais pas bon
je suis toujours là mais euh ce temps
que je me donne le matin pour être avec
les cuisiniers pour moi c'est important
j'ai dit à c'est le jour où je fais plus
ça et où je veux plus au marcher tu me
vois
[Musique]
plusin